have any of the like you know like when
we think of a guy like Diddy or we think
of a guy like hope have you had any
discussions with those guys at all about
maybe just kind of gaming them up in
terms of the space because it is a space
that
you know like you said it helps to be
somebody who came from that life you
know what I mean someone who's a smoker
someone who cares about the culture of
cannabis you know what I mean I've sat
down with Diddy I had like really really
cool like sit down with him and had a
good relationship with him personally
dude's a [__] Legend bro he's an
iconic dude for sure I've actually had
the opportunity to talk with Jay-Z as
well and you know it was a very it's
like a 30 minute call but it was like
[__] yeah was that just about just
what do you think about just like
cannabis and like where cannabis is
going and he gave me a lot of game
um
you know we just were sharing thoughts
about things and that's kind of told
them that you know like my goal with
this business is to leave it to my
daughter
but I would like to find a way to exit
in one day and get some liquidity
actually get some real cash a couple
hundred million bucks that'd be cool
yeah he gave me some real game on how to
do that I'm grateful for that I gave him
some game
we talked about doing something you just
never really moved like that but like I
was on a [__] Zoom with Jay-Z it was
pretty cool it's crazy you know what I
mean like pretty [__] cool you know
talked the whole salute to him
I'm grateful for the game you gave me I
hope that he found the game I gave him
valuable I'm here if they ever want to
chop it up again you know like Gabe
Diddy some good game he gave me some
good game you know so I feel blessed
like it's one thing to be on that list
um I even sat down with Dr Dre about
weed before really yeah like face to
face yeah what was the face-to-face
dream eating like crazy because that's
really for someone who grew up with that
uh I told you I would give you gems on
this I [__] with you you're very
consistent with like caring about my
story but like yeah shout out to slim
the mobster man
um he made a call back in the days yo
slim the mobster
[__] he was on aftermath he was in jail
and he made a call and from jail was on
the phone and you know I went and went
to go sit down with Dre they was like no
man he ain't here man he ain't here
there was like shooting me away I was
like man slim I'm here bro
he ain't trying to he said hold on
boom boom boom and I get let in I go sit
down and uh Andrea sat down with me and
I and I showed him a jar of what we
wanted to call The Chronic and it was by
far the best looking weed we've ever
produced
it was incredible beautiful it was
orange purple funky stanky just buzz
looked it was like it would look like it
was out of a [__] movie how good this
weed looked I showed him the chronic and
he was just like yeah
I [__] with it and I appreciate slim
putting this play together and you know
we'll think about it but like
I don't know if I really want to kind of
put myself in the industry and I I got
you know he told me I got money money
and I don't really want to play with
that until you know maybe it's federally
illegal I just don't want to risk it I'm
like what year was this this was like
like three or four years ago oh [__] so
not too far not too long ago yeah
um and I said I respect that and I said
can I leave this with you for yourself
or those who smoke he's like for sure
and I got like a nervous picture with
him uh Fred Wright took the picture for
me because he was air shot to Frederick
uh but yeah I think it's cool that like
being on that hip-hop list I think it's
cool because like Dre saw me he had to
see you and be like oh that's I remember
that guy yeah I remember that guy he
pitched me on this week he's doing
pretty well yeah I guess it [__]
worked for him I think it's cool because
I got a chance to share moments with
Diddy and I got a chance to share
moments with Jay-Z and those are the top
four yeah and I didn't get I've never
met Kanye you know I don't know whatever
I have no opinion on that but I'm just
saying it's cool because I've ran into
all those guys and I felt good for them
to see me up there because I told them
what I wanted to do and what I was
building at the time and now they see
they have to see the list they're like
oh [__] because the same guy that does
their evaluation and is kind of making
sure that you know they're they're their
net worth is credible and relevant is
doing mine so it's real you know I was
gonna say when that happens what is the
um whether it's the Forbes or that list
what is like the influx in people just
in your DMs or bothering you or all of a
sudden trying to [__] with you it's got
to be crazy it's crazy bro
it's crazy I'm not the answer to
anyone's problems I promise you we're
just like I would just see people like
like posting that which is never ever
like post about you or like even like
acknowledge your music or what you're
doing and it's like oh now you know now
you know this guy's on the cover of
Forbes and now you know you're [__]
I mean it's kind of cool you're
obviously the more successful you get
the more people are going to come yeah
they're going to come they're going to
come and like recognize cam but like
again for me just it's life goal [__]
because I grew up looking up to Jay-Z I
grew up looking up to Diddy who didn't
right grew up looking up to Dr Dre
Kanye's [__] no matter what anyone
says about the guy he's a [__] he's a
legend bro he's a he's a smart guy he
built he built out Yeezy hard and so
like it's cool to sit next to us guys
it's cool to like be acknowledged by the
same guys that acknowledge Him on a
wealth um you know side of things but
like [__] I just felt good when that
came out I was like damn I've talked
multiple of these guys I told what I
wanted to do I think the coolest thing
is bro I'm just getting started yeah
like we just I can't say what but Vibes
just locked into something so big no The
Vibes papers are going crazy I feel like
it's I mean I feel like it's very hard
to take off the top dog and I feel like
you guys have done a really good job of
like like if I go to any smoke shop it
used to be if I went to a smoke shop and
I saw Vibes oh you guys
that's [__] sick you know murder's my
friend that's cool it's everywhere yeah
but like the play we just logged in for
Vibes is so next level bro like and you
know you guys will see it two years from
now because I probably won't be able to
talk about it for a while but like
it's one of those plays that like goes
down to history bro and so like I'm just
getting started so if I made that list
now right it's crazy because this alone
yeah
a beast of a business yeah Vives is
about a kid hard so like you know and I
feel like cookies is nowhere close to
where it's going to be especially
because we haven't really added
International as much as we could
possibly in the future so it's crazy
because you've dealt with so many uphill
battles in every single one of these
spaces you're in like especially like I
remember when you you had the public
falling out with Josh and Rod because if
it feels like if I'm a guy who has a
company that depends on weed users
and burner comes into that space I'm
freaking the [__] out because I know
it's gonna work yeah well especially
like if I come in that space I get next
to key players that actually make that
business what it's about to be because I
start getting next to everyone real
quick yeah real quick like
I didn't just say white label of a
rolling paper for me I went and found
the best rolling paper producer I went
and found the best specialty item
producer like the Cali the girl you
could have been lazy and did what a lot
of people would have didn't just white
label some [__] yeah yeah we ain't doing
none of that and so the fact that we
started getting close to real people I
feel I think made other rolling paper
producers feel the threat but that
threat shouldn't have been felt till
today because the the document that came
through my email today is serious yeah
[__] better feel that threat
because I'm coming for the top space
enrolling paper business and I say that
with confidence with my balls hanging
down to my feet right now you know what
I mean